where is my supersuit hi everyone my
name is Tamara chambers and this is Tara
Jessa and yesterday I would saw
Incredibles 2 and was so good you guys
you guys you guys everyone it was just
so good
it was like a throwback classic where
you wanted it to be like the first it
was like upgraded when you wanted to be
upgraded it was a beautiful story it was
just such a lovely family as it was
before the characters were wonderful the
powers were crazy well utilized it was
so good it's what you wanted out of you
know 14 years right of waiting 13
however long it has been since the first
scene Incredibles so many times
Incredibles is usually in people's top
three favorite Pixar it's not their fav
and and and we've been demanding it and
it was so good I walked in expecting it
to be all kids in the theater and there
was more adults than kids and I love
that there's a post going around that's
like don't bring your kids to
Incredibles to it's not for them and
well it's just a joke that's not true it
was really lovely to like be sitting in
the theater waiting for it to start and
see just like a bunch of adults pile in
because they're just so excited for the
spill so the movie started off with a
short Pixar has their short so they play
before their movies and this woman was
called bow I read somewhere that it was
the first one directed or written or
both by a woman that's really cool it
was so weird it was so so so weird if
you don't know about is like a little
steamed bun with delicious food inside
and it's about this woman who raises
about and then you find out that that's
not what it's about it's just it's just
very touching and very beautiful my
brother and I both had tears streaming
down our eyes and like 10 seconds before
we started crying something really weird
happens this short and we were both like
is that is that what this is cool
that's not where I thought that was
going right now okay all right I had a
blast watching it I think it's my
favorite short that I've seen from them
I feel like I say this every week I'm
not gonna spoil anything there's not
really anything to spoil I'll give you
some general things that happen but
nothing like you know not like that
who the villain is and exactly what they
did and when they were stopped of course
so the movie starts off with a lovely
little recap of what happened at the end
of the last film which it wasn't like a
last time on The Incredibles it was it
was a subtle way to do it but you needed
that because it's been more than a
decade since the first film came out so
it was really well done you got you just
straight back into it you get a lot more
of the children in this film there's a
great sibling rivalry at parts
especially when they're using their
powers you see it's so much more Jack
Jack and it's hilarious
Jack Jack is such a funny funny role in
this and the way that they utilize
powers in this film is so good basically
the main story is there is a company who
wants to invest in getting superheroes
legal again and so they bring in other
superheroes and you see their powers and
their powers are so beautifully used in
some of the fights and some of the the
more intense action scenes that I was
like like it's like invested like I was
in it to win it
I wanted to see these superheroes do
well it was very exciting it was a
beautifully executed cartoon I just man
oh I want to see it again I'd use the
restroom for you there but I didn't know
when to go because it was just non-stop
it was non-stop for the whole time which
is so wonderful there was no lull and I
carefully chose the spot and I got back
and my brother was like that might have
been my favorite scene so we gotta go
see this again immediately there's a fun
role swap with mr. incredible and
Elastigirl and that's lovely to see them
work through that is in the first movie
you got so much mr. incredible and she
was stuck back
and it's kind of switched here and it's
wonderful I will watch anything that
Holly Hunter is in I want Holly hunters
career Holly Hunter you're my hero I
love you always acting in this movie is
just it's also wonderful you get a lot
more Frozone in this and you did the
last one and just I mean obviously but
the voice acting for him is just so so
so so good and you just feel for him
he's just such a good friend it doesn't
happen in every film that I see but I go
and see mostly the first viewing in
Chicago of each of these films from
public viewings and so if it's a bigger
movie if it's a Star Wars or if it's an
Incredibles 2 there's gonna be a big
audience and there was for this and the
audience is usually the people who are
dedicated and excited so if you're gonna
be in an audience where there's gonna be
like big reactions it's gonna be the
ones that I'm in usually and I love that
it's so much fun to be in a room filled
with people filled with all this energy
of just joy for seeing this film and so
there were two of those in this and it
was just it was lovely and they relapsed
and so it's just like this clapping
laughter which is so much fun such
something that like the energy I wanted
from Incredibles to was definitely in
the room it was very exciting oh my god
yes and the mode was beautiful in this
she had a late start she came in like
almost more than halfway through and was
just perfect
of course of course she was you know the
story is good when I whispered to a
character and The Incredibles 2 I might
mean it I meant it there's a really
lovely bait-and-switch with the villains
of the story it was subtle and I know a
lot of people called it but it was it
was great and and their their voice
acting was incredible and I I really
enjoyed the villain of this it was
compelling and it seems difficult and
the resolution was beautiful in the end
and it just it all came together so nice
it it did not feel obviously I would
hope that it didn't feel rushed because
it was just years and years and years
and years of waiting but it was so
lovely it was just like takes you back
to where you were when the first
Incredibles came out which I could eat
so see when was that 2004 14 years ago
holy moly where was I in 2004 I was in
eighth grade it's got a 97 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes 94% of people like it
it's just it's it's a it's a beautiful
beautiful movie and the family portrayed
is so beautiful and it's it's like this
wonderful lovely escape for two hours
III I'm this is a bold statement but I
enjoyed this more than I enjoyed The
Incredibles and I even loved The
Incredibles it's definitely my top three
favorite Pixar inside out is one
I think just because it's like the the
emotional reaction I had to it up is to
and then I think ankle wearables is
three but now it's like Incredibles what
answer holy moly what a good film this
was Yanks so so heartfelt so beautiful
so funny that audience was cracking it
the whole time and just just lovely I
will say I know a lot of Pixar films
have tearjerker moments I cried in the
like I said in in the the the first
short that played before but I didn't
cry in the film but it was just it was
non-stop like laughter was lovely it was
just like fun and light and like you
know what just like what everyone needs
right now I know I have a lot of a lot
of my friends a lot of like online
people it's just like everyone is
feeling a little bogged down for some
reason right now and I feel like it's
that buoy that you need it's like it's
just very joyful it's very sweet and
it's funny and it's good and it's pure
oh you guys I loved it I can't speak
highly enough about it
I am gonna go see it again this weekend
where is my super suit where is my
Subaru feel like this entire reaction
was just me going oh my god and then yes
I loved it happy so funny
oh my god perfect yes guys oh my god Wow
amazing so light funny Wow oh my god
thank you so much for watching it next
week
oh I think next week is Jurassic world's
but I'm gonna be out of town together
I'm gonna be at VidCon next week if
you're gonna be there let me know tweet
at me I would love to see you guys and I
will see you for Timur just saw the week
after thanks so much for watching I'll
see you soon
[Music]